modern warfare 2 and war zone 2 are
officially on the way and we're talking
about all the new details
as rumored a sequel to call of duty war
zone in 2019's modern warfare have been
revealed the news first broke on friday
february 11th on social media where
influencers discussed a round table they
were a part of the news was later
officially confirmed by activision via a
blog post according to activision the
sequels to modern warfare and warzone
have been designed together from the
ground up by infinity ward very little
is known about war zone 2 but activision
said players can look forward to a quote
massive evolution of the battle royale
formula this will include an all-new
playspace and a new sandbox mode neither
of which were discussed adding to this
youtuber jack fraggs said the developers
reportedly mentioned how no two matches
of warzone 2 should play out too similar
and it won't be the quote same old same
old this is still pretty vague and
doesn't give us any solid details to
sink our teeth into but it does
reinforce the fact that war zone 2 seems
like it's going to be a whole new ball
game for fans developers told charlie
intel that when black ops cold war
content came to war zone the battle
royale game quote didn't feel like
modern warfare but also didn't feel like
black ops either in a new video
prestigious key said that warzone was
supposed to be a one-off battle royale
but it evolved into a multi-year game
that encompasses multiple call of duty
releases developers admitted to
struggling with the integrations and
hadn't fully expected warzone to succeed
the way it did based off their
experience with blackout call of duty's
first attempt at battle royale for the
next war zone the developers are going
to react to this feedback and as for the
fate of the original war zone once war
zone 2 is released well that remains to
be seen when it comes to modern warfare
2 charlie intel reports the game will be
released this fall studio director pat
kelly said it should be obvious that the
team is making a sequel since the 2019
game sold 30 million copies basically no
information is available about modern
warfare 2 but it's rumored to be about
the colombian drug cartels activision
has been teasing modern warfare 2 and
war zone 2 so the announcement isn't a
total surprise what's more activision
management previously confirmed new call
of duty games were on the way after call
of duty vanguard in the original war
zone missed the mark by some metrics
this is all happening as microsoft moves
to acquire activision blizzard and the
call of duty franchise despite the
acquisition microsoft will keep
releasing call of duty on playstation
and it could come to nintendo switch as
well
but modern warfare 2 and war zone 2 are
still months away let's talk about the
changes that are coming to current war
zone in just a couple days in a new blog
post call of duty revealed examples of
over 30 improvements coming at the
launch of season 2 on monday february
14th these include improvements in all
forms of movement and gas mass animation
no longer interrupting operators who aim
down sights some examples of bug fixes
include performance and streaming issues
including buy station freezes voice chat
connectivity and distorted graphics our
own team has run into plenty of ongoing
bugs just this week including the
ongoing exploding gun glitch and players
hiding inside of walls but all those bug
fixes are the good news the bad news is
that fov sliders don't seem to be coming
to the current war zone on console
according to the blog post adding fov on
console in more zone creates major
performance impacts for old gen console
players the developers continued quote
our goal is for warzone to be a
performant experience on all platforms
so we do not plan to implement an fob
slider on console at this time i was a
huge fan of 2019 modern warfare so even
the tiniest little droplets of modern
warfare 2 news is enough to get me
pretty excited so let me know where you
are on the hype scale what you want to
see from the game and the new engine and
everything going forward with call of
duty and we'll see you next week
you